are you still having intercourse with
her
what is wrong with you she is engaged
did you ever have intercourse in this
office
are you serious
where
Dwight
it seems like you already know where
party planning's a real high like a
runner's high
hey Dwight Stanley
one way or another you are going to come
with me to make this sale pass can you
just let me out of here before whatever
comes next don't worry it's just a bull
tranquilizer nothing to be alarmed about
it's just a man pointing a bull
tranquilizer at a co-worker Dwight you
do not learn do you for threat to be
credible
no you didn't I'm sick of you
it's all right Andy approved it
man he's really in twinkle town now is
he gonna be okay
I mean weren't those darts intended for
an animal like
two to three times larger than him okay
this dosage was meant for a very small
ball and Stanley's got way more body fat
than they do you give him three shots
got about 45 minutes to get him to the
client before he comes to grab his feet
all right
it's about as good as that's gonna be
okay now here's the plan I'm gonna
launch him I need you to go down to the
bottom and catch him catch yeah I can't
catch him he's like 250 pounds use your
hands and just blunt his descent okay
he's gonna be moving slowly it's only
one it's 15 feet down it's at a 45
degree angle get set in your haunches
it's like you're catching a medicine the
size of my lunch is
okay just hit me you'll see I can't
because uh just got a manicure so oh
queer eye queer eye that's a good show
important show
go ahead do it just time do I punch you
no yeah well that would be kind of
worthless because I know a ton of 14
year old girls are going to kick his ass
you know a ton of 14 year old girls what
belt are they look Dwight is a wuss when
we rented Armageddon no cried at the end
of it I told you that was because it was
New Year's Eve and it started to snow at
exactly midnight and Bruce Willis ain't
gonna leave him on the asteroid okay
I'll punch you oh okay here we go all
right come on go oh
yep
looking good
oh what a day what a day Dwight are you
carrying a gun The holster was a gift
from my great uncle honk um I don't know
I guess he's saying that he's proud of
me Dwight guns make me really
uncomfortable the gun is just an
accessory to the holster okay I can't
walk around wearing an empty holster why
do you need to wear the holster at all
why do you need to keep wearing those
booby shirts all the time thank you you
could put your cell phone in it instead
hello
you could put a banana in it why would I
put a banana in my holster in case you
weren't hungry now but you got hungry
later Dwight no gun okay don't make us
call Joe okay all right fine everyone
calm down someone get me a banana sorry
I freaked you guys out
oh
loud
I could save the branch really if you
let me run it
okay okay I can run it
what would you do differently
mostly get rid of waste which is half
the people there
clean house
right here it's all for me
thank you what you must feel strongly to
speak with me it's way behind Michael's
back and turn on so many of your
co-workers
the decision to turn on Michael was
difficult
but once I did it I didn't look back and
mostly I feel that Michael would approve
it's really what's best for the branch
and I could care less about my
co-workers
so
here we are
it's all on the table
I want the branch
wait your decision
oh by the way
there's a new Ann Taylor outlet store
near here I know you like their earrings
where is it okay I will only need two
things a roll of duct tape and a knife
I'm on it okay 30 minutes or less please
come back
save the receipts
hey what let's see if any of these will
work hey hey White
Dwight I keep various Weaponry
strategically placed around the office
I saved Jim's life with a can of pepper
spray I had velcroed under my desk
people say oh it's dangerous to keep
weapons in the home or the workplace
well I say it's better to be hurt by
someone you know accidentally
than by a stranger on purpose
thank you
how'd that get there
there's a star-shaped thing taped under
the kitchen table thanks Amanda
Merry Christmas
no why why did you bring that here don't
worry she's dead oh wait
he's dead why what
I accidentally ran over it it's a
Christmas miracle well get it out of
here relax okay and because this is
Christmas I am going to roast this goose
and prepare it with a wild rice dressing
do we have any cayenne pepper in the
kitchen
today smoking is going to save lives
does anyone smell anything smoky
did you bring your jerky in again
oh my goodness what's the procedure what
do we do people oh how did that happen
it's out in the hall no we don't know
that the smoke could be coming through
an air duct oh my God okay it's
happening everybody stay calm what's the
procedure everyone what's the procedure
calm down no no Michael no touch the
handle if it's hot there could be a fire
in the hallway
[Music]
things can be replaced Phyllis people
human lives however can
no
this one's hot too okay we're trapped
everyone for himself
okay okay
have you ever seen a burn victim okay
use a watch to cover the mouth a rag a
damp rag perhaps
let's remember those procedures oh my
God that's the wrong way we've already
tried that remember your exit points
exit points people what's next stay
alive I'm getting help pull me up you're
too heavy I only weigh 82 pounds
how about 9-1-1
what do we do use this surge of fear and
adrenaline to sharpen your
decision-making okay I am not dying come
on
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
attention
employees of Dunder Mifflin this has
been a test of our emergency
preparedness there is no fire it was
only a simulation what